fdp-politikerin caroline preißler hatte
selbst corona war gestern auf der
demonstration um dort mit den
demonstranten ins gespräch zu kommen und
wir wollen sie jetzt dazu befragen wie
das gelaufen ist sie ist mir
zugeschaltet guten abend frau preißler
im truck bookmarken wie lief das gestern
ab was haben sie zu den demonstranten
gesagt und wie waren die reaktionen
ich habe mir ein schild gemalt und stand
auf der demonstration mit einem
gesprächsangebot an das war ja das kona
maßnahmen auf ihre verhältnismäßigkeit
überprüft werden sollten
und da ich selber an cholera erkrankt
war in der vergangenheit dachte ich dass
ich meinen beitrag zu dieser diskussion
leisten kann und ich finde es durchaus
legitim kohona maßnahmen
obwohl also in regelmäßigen abständen
auf ihre weiteres mäßig zu überprüfen
die demonstranten wollen ja durchaus
mehr als nur überprüfen dort war ja ein
wilder mix an menschen normale bürger
die die maßnahmen kritisch sehen aber
auch verschwörungstheoretiker
rechtsradikale was konnten sie dort
beobachten und wir haben die menschen
dort auf sie reagiert ich habe einige
sehr höfliche menschen getroffen und
lockere gespräche geführt wir sind
natürlich nicht überein gekommen meine
gesprächspartner und ich denn die hatten
natürlich der vorgefertigte meinung sie
sind hatten einen großen leidensdruck
als sie auf die demonstrationen gegangen
sind aber
die situation veränderte sich auch im
laufe des tages schon als ich morgens
ankam war sehr deutlich zu sehen dass
die demonstrationen stark durchzogen war
von bürgern von nazis und menschen mit
inhalten die nicht auf dem boden der
verfassung standen und gegen mittag
verschafften sich die situation auch für
mich habe dann auch am frühen nachmittag
in ort verlassen bin aber der festen
meinung das ist genauso funktionieren
muss politik muss auf jeden bürger
zugehen und dahin gehen wo der schuh
drückt und gestern drückte der in berlin
und deswegen war es genau der richtige
ort für mich im ausland wird deutschland
für den umgang mit der pandemie ja oft
gelobt warum glauben sie sind so viele
menschen hier unzufrieden skeptisch ja
oder widersprechen völlig der strategie
der regierung
ich kann mir das gut vorstellen dass es
daran liegt dass wir gerade in der zeit
der pandemie von oben durch regiert
wurden das war eine kritische situation
und es musste schnell gehandelt werden
wir haben nicht die transparenz gab wie
wir sie sonst im politischen alltag
erleben und wenn man eben immer nur
entscheidungen vorgesetzt bekommt und
oft auch sehr kurzfristig dann führt es
dazu dass man sich nicht mitgenommen
führt als bürger und ich habe gestern
die großen leidensdruck bei den menschen
gefühlt waren sehr aufgewühlt das ging
um viele gefühle und sie haben sich als
bürgerinnen und bürger eben bevormundet
gefühlt und eben nicht als teilhaben
menschen in deutschland ja in
deutschland
sie sprechen über die bürger die dort
gestern im mitgelaufen sind eher können
die sich wirklich auch noch rausreden
dass sie nicht wussten mit wen sie dort
seite an seite marschierten wir haben ja
die bilder gesehen die demonstration
sagten sie auch selbst war durchaus
durchzogen von rechtsradikalen von
verschwörungstheoretikern ja das ist so
es gibt niemanden der behaupten kann
dass er nicht gewusst hat was dort oft
dieser demonstration passieren wird war
von morgen an da und ich konnte meine
augen nicht verschließen die
tätowierungen die plakate die äußerungen
das auftreten der menschen der
identitäten bewegungen der nazis afd der
person die ganz deutlich eben nicht nur
geringer maßnahmen überprüfen wollten
sondern eher einen kurzen prozess
forderten war schon deutlich zu sehen
und es gibt niemanden der behaupten kann
er hat nicht gewusst worauf er sich da
gestern einlassen ausgeschlossen
frau preisseite es eingangs sie waren
selbst an corona erkrankt wie verlief
die krankheit bei ihnen und auch wie
sehen sie jetzt diese krankheit diese
pandemie sieht man dass nach einer
erkrankung vielleicht mit anderen augen
auch mit blick auf die maßnahmen die
ergriffen werden natürlich erfahre ich
viel auf dieser demonstrationen was
menschen die ihm keine krone
erkrankungen haben eben dazu denken und
ganz oft da ich den vergleich gehört
dass es eben naja ein schnupfen eine
leichte grippe oder in nichts ist ganz
unabhängig von weiteren verschwörungs
ansetzen
doch gegen grippe kann ich mich halten
und kann auch vorsorge betreiben und sie
ist eben auch nicht so hoch ansteckend
wie diese erkrankungen die ich in der
vergangenheit erlebt habe und ich hatte
nur ein mittel schweren verlauf und
trotzdem bin ich jetzt fünf monate was
sechs monate später immer noch
beeinträchtigt es geht mir gut
aber ich habe zipperlein die ich nicht
hätte wenn er nicht da gewesen wäre und
deshalb halte ich diese krankheit für
sehr gefährlich dann wenn es mich als
gesunde frau im mittleren alter so
heftig erwischen konnte an stelle ich
mir das risiko für lehrende und kinder
für menschen in risikogruppen oder
altersheim im besonders hoch war und ich
wünsche mir dass wir lösungen finden die
nicht unsere nächsten in gefahr bringen
und es geht ihm gerade nicht um das
recht auf
durch solche oder um ein grundrecht auf
ansteckung es geht vielmehr darum dass
ich
meinen nächsten schützen muss und nicht
in finden sich infizieren das hat mich
gestern schon sehr getroffen
ich habe ganz viel feedback bekommen von
menschen die gesagt haben
ach komm ein bisschen schwund ist immer
in dem fall wäre ich schwund gewesen und
ich war dankbar und sehr erleichtert
dass ich im krankenhaus war und wieder
genesen sind
sie sprachen von zipperlein unter den
sind noch leiden fünf monate nach der
erkrankung darf ich sie fragen welche
zipperlein das sind welche
gesundheitlichen beschwerden sie nach
ihrer corona erkrankung dennoch haben ja
zum beispiel gegen wir drei monate nach
der krone erkrankung sehr viele haare
aus ich wurde fast war es hat ungefähr
neun wochen gedauert hatte
sprachstörungen und die man sich so
vorstellen kann dass ich einen satz im
kopf gebildet habe aber mein hund hat
man ein anderer satz verlassen des boten
also wörter vertauscht auf dem weg von
amgen und zum mund
dann gibt es noch so andere sachen die
in suez herz betreffen ich habe
engegefühl in der brust und stechende
herzschmerzen und es ist nicht so dass
man wenn man negativ ist und nicht mehr
ansteckend ist man danach gesund ist es
dauert länger ich bin zuversichtlich
dass ich das über stehe aber ich
wünschte mir ich hätte es nicht
durchmachen
caroline preißler selbst an corona
erkrankt gewesen und gestern auf den
demonstrationen gewesen um in den dialog
zu kommen dort mit den demonstranten
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch danke